[Music]
migrants fleeing conflict persecution
and poverty continue to arrive on
Europe's Shores
it's a perilous journey with thousands
dying at sea those that do make it hope
to stay in Europe millions have applied
for asylum status in the past few years
the EU law that determines which country
is responsible for processing an asylum
application is called the Dublin
regulation but it isn't working it
collapsed in 2015 with a big influx of
asylum seekers we should have a fair
distribution of people so that each and
every member state takes its fair share
of the asylum seekers at present asylum
applications are processed at national
level the country through which the
asylum seeker first entered the EU is
responsible frontline states like Greece
and Italy bear the brunt in future
applications should be automatically
collected at the EU level and
distributed based on the population and
GDP of each member state we should have
a system put in place that functions
irrespective of if there is a big influx
or a lower influx of people so that we
don't have any more to put emergency
measures in place a system that can
handle the magnitude of the problem a
system with shared responsibility at its
core
you